salut juju salut casimir tu m'as l'air
de tenir une forme splendide ce matin
ouais j'ai combat paulette je sens bon
j'ai très envie de danser avec toi tu
veux qu'on fasse notre danse aujourd'hui
ouais et alors pas d'accord mais alors
laisse moi le temps d'aller le changer
at d'accord tient pendant ce temps là
moi je vais aller chercher ma canne tam
padam padam padam par mon papa pas les
enfants les enfants venez venez je n'ai
pris deux mois
venez vous asseoir à côté de moi venez
venez tous bien vite à côté de moi vous
allez me rendre un très grand service
vient là bien qu'elle a bien à côté de
moi viens vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
défaut savait tous que c'est un défaut
tu sais ni vis ici quelque chose confie
même qu'on fait mal tu peux me décider
des défauts qui marque
oui mais qu'est ce que c'est des faux
qu'est ce que tu me système des fausses
et par mois par exemple être avast
défaut non c'est pas un défaut au
travail c'est un défaut au travail après
tu peux m'en citer d'autres de défaut
pour être voleur très bien ensuite tu
connais des défauts qu'est-ce qui a
reconnu être un bandit oui d'accord mais
par exemple être méchant très bien les
méchancetés un grand défaut être menteur
c'est un défaut c'est un grand défaut
être un menteur ensuite l'égoïsme par
exemple c'est pas un défaut être égoïste
très bien et être distrait vous savez ce
que c'est être distrait oui c'est pas un
défaut oui à battre est bien vrai très
gentils vous rendez un très grand
service bien écoutez je vous remercie
beaucoup les enfants au revoir à bientôt
jeu d enfant attend dé moi j'ai besoin
de vous un mené par ici
pour sûr vous savez que les qualités
c'est le contraire des défauts 1 les
qualités le contraire des défauts alors
je voudrais que vous me donniez des noms
de qualité un alors recherché
réfléchissez un petit peu pardon entre
gentils être gentil à ça c'est une
qualité d'être gentil très bien et très
bien jean françois gentil à toi toi non
à etoy un travailleur à la plus belle
des qualités enfin c'est ce que me dit
mon chef
et toi y'a pas trouvé une qualité
cherche bien allez allez allez
généreux une bonne qualité j'ai n'ai
remix voilà à toi a très bien oui oui un
peu ça c'en est une
oui bien sûr bombay d'être obéissent en
voilà une bonne qualité b sam en fait
quelques-unes déjà de qualité par dont
deux de donner beaucoup d'argent d'être
généreux mais c'est ce qu'on a dit
d'ailleurs déjà tout allait bien les
enfants
je vous remercie bien à aller jouer
maintenant vous pouvez continuer il
était temps voilà que signe
qu'est ce que c'est il faut que je te
parle à moi aussi j'ai des choses à te
dire tiens vous étiez là vous pour sur
le hasard fait quelquefois bien les
choses demande si c'est vraiment le
hasard
que voulez-vous insinuer monsieur du
snob mais mon cher ami juste souhait est
que vous êtes sûr que c'est à moi que
vous voulez parler à incontestable nous
découvrent que images effet une étude
sérieuse et scientifique son caractère
et je leur regret de te dire que tu n'as
que des défauts promesses et c'est
affreux ça mais non casimir moi aussi
justement j'ai fait une étude sur ton
caractère curieux hasard pour sûr tu n'a
que des qualités à lavaré d'étonner mais
laissez moi vous donner le résultat de
mon étude qui est elle sérieuse et
scientifique premier défaut la curiosité
la curiosité
ben moi je les comme première qualité la
curiosité une qualité que d'aller
regarder écouter tout ce qui ne vous
concerne pas mais la curiosité de
kazimierz et sa soif de s'instruire
c'est d'apprendre plein de choses pour
devenir aussi savant que françois alors
quoi c'est une qualité ou un défaut une
taille des qualités et ma vitre deuxième
défaut l'obstination obstine race est
aussi sur ma liste or une bien belle
qualité pareil
c'est que d'être têtu et de par
reconnaître qu on dira qu'on vient de
faire une bêtise mais l'obstination de
casimir lui permet de poursuivre un
effort malgré les embûches et de
parvenir au but c'est ce sublime bon
troisième défaut la prodigalité et
attendait ccc quoi là on dit gamache la
pro 10 gars lite et la prodigalité un
horrible défaut que signifie que tu
dépenses sans raisonner tout ce que tu
as
pour sûr je ne connais pas de plus belle
qualité
casimir casimir c'est vrai n'a rien pour
lui il ne garde en rien il donne tout
aux autres oui c'était un être d'une
exceptionnelle beauté
merci mon cher ami je constate avec
regret que vous avez choisi à chaque
fois de dire le contraire de ce que
j'affirme a vraiment monsieur du som
vous me feriez de la peine en pensant
une chose pareille c'est voyons sous le
radar si tous les défauts que vous citez
sont sur ma liste des qualités c'est
vraiment ça je vois ça vous a posé une
question tiens tu étais là qu'il n'y a
pas qu'une tête de tous nous dérange
nous parlons sérieusement que oui alors
je disais vous êtes quand même en train
de parler de mes qualités et des défauts
mais si vous voulez j'avais complètement
oublié bombe un outil plutôt que gémir
je voudrais savoir si quand je danse
est ce que c'est une qualité ou un
défaut
assurément c'est un des taux à je ne
suis pas d'accord non dans che comme un
quasi mais russe mais c'est une très
grande qualité
c'est un défaut une qualité à défaut une
galette à lui
les disputes et ils n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord pour savoir si donc
c'est comme casimir us c'est une qualité
ou un défaut mais c'est simple
asseyez-vous tous les deux sur le vent
regardez casimir danser et vous jugerez
ensuite un service une excellente idée
très bon j'espère qu'après cette
démonstration chez rémy vous conviendrez
que j'avais raison
pour sûr après cette danse vous rangerez
à mon avis alors attention
musica
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bon
m
oui
[Musique]
joe danger alors facteurs danser comme
un casimir us c'est une qualité mois
défaut pour sûr c'est une grande de
qualité du snav
chers amis je reste convaincu que c'est
un défaut vous avez raison monsieur du
snav
j'en ai connu des faux enfin presque car
j'ai au moins une qualité est là qu'elle
est bien c'est que moi monsieur je ne
suis pas snob haut
[Musique]